when you order food
what foods do you absolutely avoid uh
it's it so i i interpret questions as
you can see
you have to forgive me so here's another
way to ask that
tom should i read labels right
that's that's another way to ask that
sure tom's answer
no if it has a label don't eat it
in other words people don't need it in
other words you go to the store
or you go to a market or you go to a
tree and you see that's an apple
you don't need a label that's a fish
or here's another way to say that we
know that
the people in 1920 didn't have heart
attacks
eat what they ate they had bacon and
eggs for breakfast
the bacon was on pasture-raised pigs
because if you keep a feet a pig in
confinement
it will become toxic and then it will
quote get infected just so that's
helpful right there what you just said
is helpful pasture-raised pigs
right right pasture-raised pigs cows
that are on
pasture so that they have all the
healthy nutrients
and then freshly ground wheat that you
bake into sourdough bread
and vegetables from your garden and if
it has a label don't eat it
you